mais c'est évident et j'en veux pour
preuve les nombreuses rencontres que
j'ai avec des jeunes qui voudraient
revenir mais qui ne peuvent pas parce
que rien n'a été préparé entre le moment
ils sont partis faire des études et
quand ils reviennent ont l'impression
d'être un statu quo on vient de parler
du transport c'est que depuis combien
d'années en parle du transport + attend
plus de 20 ans voilà je pense que tout
est dit comment alors comment rendre la
martinique attractive à ce mouvement
notamment alors pour ces jeunes mais
aussi pour les investisseurs qui font
aussi défaut
écoutez moi je n'ai pas un catalogue de
solutions mais ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que à partir du moment où vous
donnez à l'investisseur des raisons
d'avoir confiance en vous une stabilité
que quel que soit le pouvoir politique
en place
on a le sentiment qu'il ya une
continuité dans la vision est dans
l'action ce n'est pas le gars non ce
n'est pas le cas à ce moment là vous
allez pouvoir attirer des investisseurs
du monde entier est un autre élément il
faut aussi que le monde économique soit
suffisamment ouvert pour accueillir
également des investisseurs étrangers
ce parce que c'est un jeu gagnant
gagnant vous n'allez pas rêver que des
gens viennent déverser de l'argent chez
vous sans qu'ils aient un gain en
contrepartie le monde économique
martinique a d ailleurs je dis
simplement qu'il faut l'ouvrir
aujourd'hui on est à l'ère des start up
aujourd'hui on est à allaire des
auto-entrepreneurs donc il ya de la
place pour tout le monde il ya surtout
de la place pour l'innovation et ce
n'est pas parce que vous n'avez pas pu
vous n'avez pas pensé à une innovation
dans votre entreprise qu'il n'ya pas
l'espace pour créer cette innovation
vous êtes en train c'est assez
intéressant si vous êtes en train de
dire c'est à dire que si on n'a pas
pensé à cette innovation sa
déconstruction met des bâtons dans les
roues à ceux qui veulent créer je pense
qu'il y a effectivement beaucoup de
freins et j'en ai moi même été victime
donc je sais de quoi je parle
et par conséquent si vous voulez garder
vos jeunes données lan suffisamment
d'espacé pour être créatif donnez-leur
suffisamment de latitude pour s'exprimer
et vous verrez justement qu'à partir de
votre propre jeunes de votre propre
population
vous allez trouver un moyen de vous
rattachés au reste du monde alors
justement quel rôle peut plus
aujourd'hui la martinique dans ce
concert économique mondiale on a
beaucoup parlé du cas du canal de panama
et qui devait booster les échanges de
marchandises entre autres alors bah
écoutez là aussi ça ne s'improvise pas
jeudi on a beaucoup parlé mais on n'a
peut-être pas travaillé suffisamment le
sujet n'est pas offensive
la martinique n'est pas suffisamment
offensive n est pas suffisamment
proactive et ça c'est une c'est une
réalité je veux dire tout le monde peut
être au courant de ce qui se passe dans
le monde
mais il suffit pas d'en parler pour
participer à laval ce mondial il faut
aller chercher les moyens de se
raccrocher à tous d'avoir des idées
aussi
il faut avoir les idées mais faut avoir
envie d'abord je suis désolé je n'ai pas
toujours rencontré des gens qui avaient
envie
voilà donc il faut avoir envie il faut y
aller faut des fois il faut vraiment
mettre les mains dans le cambouis comme
on dit voilà le temps pour dépeindre un
tableau noir de 2,2 de la martinique
pas du tout pas du tout j'ai beaucoup
d'espoir c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que je
suis encore là je suis je je pense que
je suis aujourd'hui dans une génération
intermédiaire vous avez suivi au cours
des vingt dernières années un certain
nombre de péripéties que j'ai pu avoir
dans ma vie professionnelle je suis
encore là c'est que je prends la
martinique
je crois qu'il y a des gens très positif
et avec d une volonté d'agir et qu'à un
moment donné il y aura donc une les
verrous ont sauté
c'est d'autant plus dur quand on les
femmes vous étiez d'ailleurs la
présidente de martinique pionnière qui a
fermé ses pompes qui a été liquidée il
faut aller de l'avant
est ce qu'aujourd'hui pour une femme
c'est d'autant plus difficile de créer
une entreprise de monter une entreprise
de et de vouloir réussir dans son dans
son pays un matin c'est très
symptomatique ce que vous venez de
décrire je rappelle que l'association
dans laquelle j'étais bénévole
a vu passer plus de 250 femmes en quatre
ans et que nous sommes restés quinze
mois sans un euro d'argent public alors
même que l'europe finance à 90% ce type
de structure qui aide les femmes à créer
des entreprises innovantes
ça c'est un premier point le deuxième
point c'est que bien sûr que c'est
difficile c'est tellement difficile que
symboliquement vous avez liquide est à
dire qu on ait symboliquement qu on a
voulu casser un outil qui pourtant était
au bénéfice des femmes de ce pays
maman technique pionnière accueilli en
son sein beaucoup de femmes qui
n'avaient pas de problèmes et beaucoup
de femmes aussi qui avait connu des
accidents pas un coup ça veut dire qu'un
accident de parcours
c'est on parle d'inceste on parle de
viol en général on parle de mari violent
ou de compagnon violent et c'est des
femmes qui par l'outil économique pas le
développement est en phase de
reconstruction étaient en phase de
reconstruction parce que elle devenait
plus autonome économiquement donc plus
libres de leurs choix et casser un outil
comme ça il ne rien mettre à la place il
ya vraiment de quoi s'interroger sur la
volonté de faire progresser et la femme
mais la femme en la femme entrepreneur
ou en en tunique en matière d'égalité
hommes femmes du pays comme l'allemagne
ou et l'islande ont pris de nouvelles
lois visant à réduire les écarts de
salaires liées au sexe en islande par
exemple depuis le 1er janvier les
entreprises privées et les services
publics employant plus de 25 personnes
doivent disposer d'un document
certifiant que l' équilibre salariale
est appliqué une bonne mesure
de toute façon tout ce qui va dans le
sens de des réductions de disparités
entre les hommes et les femmes c'est ça
ne peut être que positive en france est
à la traîne par rapport à notre
gouvernement a pris des résolutions on
sait aujourd'hui qui en moyenne 16 %
d'écart entre les salaires des hommes et
des femmes et la france est également en
train de mettre en place un certain
nombre de dispositifs pour contrôler les
points courage et pour inciter alors
vous avez été on change de sujet tout ce
qu'on vous avez été l'une des premières
en martinique à écrire
dire que vous avez été victime de
harcèlement sexuel vous avez comme on
dit balancer votre port sur les réseaux
sociaux d'ailleurs vous êtes plus
balances ton port ou bien mis tous vous
voyez là je n'aime pas la question
réellement ce qui ce que j'ai voulu dire
et des années après parce que là ça nous
ramène encore au sujet de martin
pionnière je n'ai pas voulu effrayer les
femmes qui fréquentaient cet incubateur
c'est-à-dire ce lieu de réseautage et de
création mais c'est aussi symptomatique
quand on reçoit un courrier comme ça
qu'on est bénévole qu'on a rien volé à
personne et qu'on essaye juste de
promouvoir la femme et de l'accompagner
dans son accomplissement professionnel
et personnel il ya quand même de quoi
s'inquiéter
et je me suis dit mais c'est très bien
tout ça on parle de balances ton pot à
l'international comme si ça n'existait
pas ici mais quelque part il ya quand
même des gens assez tordu pour envoyer
ce genre de course vous avez vous avez
voulu faire éclater faire voler en
éclats les l'hypocrisie ambiante square
mais absolument il faut dire aux gens ce
qui existe et il faut dire encore une
fois que la liquidation d'une
association comme celle là découle d'un
certain état d'esprit exprimés ou non
avoués ou non mais c'est très
symptomatique de cette relation homme
femme qui lit adam romantique que vous
inspire la tribune et ce sera la
dernière question la tribune du
collectif 10 ans femmes publiée dans le
monde pour je cite défendre une liberté
d'importuner indispensable à la liberté
sexuelle
est ce que vous pensez vraiment qu'on
ait besoin d'une tribune au sujet de la
liberté d'importuner je veux dire à une
femme qui a agressé elle sait quand elle
est agressée donc il faut arrêter je
pense que ses fans auraient mieux fait
d'aller prendre le café et puis le
rester chez elles sont de la gaza
nouvelle je vous remercie
c'est moi qui vous remercie bonne
journée l écoute de nos programmes merci
au revoir